the armed Insurrection launched by the
chief of the paramilitary Wagner group
eviani pregosian lasted less than a day
but it was the biggest challenge to the
rule of the Russian president
on Saturday Wagner seized the Southern
military District headquarters in the
city of rostov the main logistical hub
for Russian forces operating in Ukraine
they were rolling towards Moscow when a
deal set to be negotiated by the
belarussian president between Prague and
Putin averted a potential confrontation
the Wall Street journal's Moscow bureau
chief Ann Simmons explains what the
short-lived Mutiny means for Putin
this crisis is the most significant test
I believe that Putin has faced in his 23
year old
Putin had to back down to a certain
degree because he had to go to the
negotiating table in the morning on
Saturday we had Vladimir Putin accusing
pre-gaussian of instigating an armed
Rebellion by the evening we were seeing
that forgotten is Forgiven and the
charge is dropped now we do not know
what kind of deal pregosian got out of
this it is said that he will be going to
Belarus but the Russian population has
now seen that President Putin isn't as
Invincible this is definitely expose
vulnerability of his power in the eyes
of the Russian Elite in terms of what
this crisis shows
it shows that there was very little
resistance to prigorjin on his way to
Moscow
the very fact that pre-gaussian and his
troops were able to get within Striking
Distance of Moscow speaks volumes it
shows on the one hand that soldiers in
the Russian military maybe weren't
willing to take up arms against
his force is quite feared and we also
have to note that a large portion of
Russia's Army is now on the front lines
of Ukraine also there were pictures and
videos of people actually greeting
precaution and his troops at least in
the rustov in the South that shows that
maybe there is this level of support for
pre-gaussian that Putin probably
underestimated
the question now will be how does
Vladimir Putin regain the narrative but
despite that slight glitch nothing has
changed I still have power but it's
definitely clear that his power at least
the perception of his power has been
eroded